[Music]
reboot yeah yeah I'm doing a pilot in
January and it's a spin-off to Pretty
Little Liars such as amazing I'm so glad
to announce it actually I realized that
I can announce it today which I was kind
of blindsided about there's water right
which I'm so excited about gotta be
something new I love that I guess play
Alison still I mean you know it's a
character that's dear to my heart for
seven years
yeah and it's a fun new world and
Marlene our producer is incredible she's
just a genius and so I can't wait to be
on this journey with everybody get them
on the show I would love that yeah
[Music]
I'm so much happier than last week I
feel so much more confident I can
breathe now I'm nerves have been on this
show for the most people live it got you
last week a little bit we talked about
it but man they seemed like it seemed
like you're an old pro at this well I
wouldn't say that but I really I feel so
good this has been such an amazing
experience it looks a little tough in
rehearsal a bit of a yeah oh my gosh
yeah thank goodness he's so attractive I
know right and the Russian accent hey
listen we've been doing a little like
ballroom face I'm going to count to
three and three two one hit we had the
sultry sexy face and then to the head
like that happy that was so good
[Music]
you